>> I think that the most important innovation,
development that is
likely to impact on the state of the world
in the coming decades is the
fact that we have an increasing capacity in
poor countries to come up
with innovations.
Because up to now innovations have been done
mainly in rich countries.
And they have assumed a rich country context.
So you have television changer which assumes
you have already a
television.
You had an Internet solution that assumes
you already have broadband
access or a computer.
So innovations in rich countries have trouble
moving towards poor
countries because the context that they assume
is not there.
But as you have more and more of the capacity
to innovate in poor
countries in China, in India, in Latin Americas,
more and more products
are being designed taking the reality of the
customer, of those
customers to heart.
So, for example, since the Middle Ages, banks
were invented.
Banks are around for 700 years.
Banks only service about 30 percent of people.
Only about 30 percent of humans are in the
banking system.
Cell phones are covering more or less over
70 percent of the adult
population of the world.
Well, if we can tag onto the cell phone things
that are currently being
distributed or sold through banking systems
in countries that don't
have that penetration of the banking system,
we will incorporate a ton
of people to finance.
We will incorporate a ton of people to access
to medical knowledge that
they wouldn't otherwise have because now they
are connected.
But the people who are going to be thinking
about those innovations who
are going to be thinking about or coming up
with those ideas are people
in poorer countries who have those poor citizens
as their main concern
as their main goal and they're taking into
account the reality.
So innovation, as innovation spreads to poorer
countries solutions are
going to be more adequate for the poor.